le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
elle creuse les montagnes en jambes les
rivières se faufile à travers le paysage
escarpé de lille les routes représentent
un enjeu majeur pour le développement de
notre territoire
depuis la décentralisation le
département assure la gestion de 720 km
de routes
ce sont les utm les unités territoriales
routière qui oeuvrent au quotidien à
l'entretien des voiries ses équipes
célèbrent leur 20 ans d'existence cette
année
[Musique]
comme chaque matin le fourgon jaune et
bleu de yens sillonnent la route du
guillaume mais là on va sur les d 3 1
contre la suisse présente d'ailleurs une
branche là et là on va fêter à
mentionner sur cette branche 1 mais
voilà les valises la ressource tout
juste le côté gauche et droit d'un conte
ne sont pas des hcr il ya des voitures
c'est donc en sécurité que les agents de
l'utm unités territoriales routières
vont leur première intervention du jour
une petite mission d'élagage pour
dégager la route
c'est la période de canne à sucre et les
pactes belle qui est facteur passe et je
pense beaucoup
yann repère aussi des gravillons sur la
chaussée avec des paillettes des balises
là on fait un tué nettoyage assez japon
ni dérive où la présence de gravillons
la vie est comme un danger peut en
cacher un autre
sous la poussière et les graviers les
agents sont une autre découverte la
foule sur le bord des rues main ouah
voir bp la robine dans la baie robert
froid ces petites interventions sont le
quotidien de gagner son équipe
elles sont aux patrouilleurs sur une
portion de la route départementale 3 ils
ceinture les hauts de l'ouest le rôle
entretenir la voirie et s'assurer qu'il
n'y a pas de danger pour les usagers
le plus souvent je présente le gasoil
chaussée du béton des 0,20 à 10 euros la
campagne beaucoup faible taux est même
des bronzes des harkis dedans voilà dix
huit ans que yann travail dans les
huttes et r depuis la création de ces
unités
il a constaté une évolution du réseau
routier au début on était plus dégradée
mais la dalle ensemble fait la robella
la route quand même bien bien quelques
kilomètres plus loin
l'équipe repère de nouveau de la
poussière et des gravillons sur la
chaussée va être dangereux et surtout
quoi
trop frêle jeune fan de danse arts à
l'e3 les accidents tous les jouets ya
toujours quelqu'un est tout à fait à son
expérience et son enthousiasme il ya un
espèrent les transmettre nouveau venu de
son équipe ont fait 3 mois déjà venus
travailler sinon j'aime bien le boulot
et ça pour autant pour les voitures
surtout de l'autre côté de l'île vers
saint-andré des travaux d'une plus
grande ampleur sont en cours mais c'est
un quartier bras des chevrettes sur un
aménagement donc de la r&d au
départemental numéro 46 ici il s'agit de
modifier le tracé de la route actuelle
est de construire un nouveau pont alors
ici vous voyez les ouvrages de petit
gabarit il ne permettait pas
l'écoulement donc de cette ravine pour
des événements importants de saison
cyclonique
du coup nous refaisons un ouvrage
beaucoup plus important qui fait 6
mètres de largeur et 3 mètres de hauteur
là on peut voir donc le futur ouvrage de
franchissement donc de la ravine écoles
mentionne sur lequel passera notre
nouvelle route des modifications
nécessaires à la sécurité de la
circulation mais aussi à celle des
habitants du quartier la ravine qu'on
voit tout au fond là-bas donc donc
débordé au dessus du chemin pourra
mousseline emprunter notre route
départementale et donc inondé les
riverains tels que celui ci car dans
cette région de l'île lui tr doit
composer avec une difficulté majeure
les fortes pluies et ce carrefour de la
rd 46 n'est pas le seul point noir du
réseau les routes les plus
problématiques pour lutter reste c'est
effectivement les route de salazie rd48
la plus connue qui sont effectivement
soumis à des aléas et notamment
climatiques et géologiques qui entraîne
des chutes de pierres fréquentes et donc
on sait que pour allah salazie ya qu une
seule route quoi
climat topographie sismologie pas facile
de combiner ces facteurs avec
l'augmentation de la population
aujourd'hui le développement du réseau
routier est un enjeu capital pour notre
département les routes départementales
sont ancrées dans notre quotidien
chaque citoyen en pointe forcément
chaque jour une route départementale
elles sont des routes à forte
circulation dix mille voix des fois
quinze mille véhicules jour raison pour
laquelle nous avons augmenté doublé
depuis l'arrivée de la nouvelle majorité
le budget des routes qui est passé à 20
millions d'euros chaque année
à côté de cela on a une vision à long
terme pour développer de nouveaux
territoires des nouveaux quartiers avec
notamment ce projet de route des eaux du
nord et de l'est qui va relier cette
marie à saint benoît c'est un projet
d'envergure qui va compléter notre
ceinture routière qui est déjà
importante avec la route des tamarins et
qui va se développer maintenant dans le
nord et l'est
un nouvel axe qui pourra compter sur les
soins quotidiens d'à gens aussi
passionnés que yann et ses collègues
[Musique]
les unités territoriales routière se
divise dans quatre territoires nord sud
est et ouest
elle compte près de 300 agents qui
assurent l'entretien de 720 km de routes
départementales les routes
départementales permettent notamment le
désenclavement des eaux de l'île
certains axes joue un rôle stratégique
comme la rd48 seul accès à salazie la
rd41 la route de la montagne ou encore
la future route des eaux de l'est qui
reliera sainte marie à saint benoît pour
plus de renseignements sur les ut air et
les routes départementales
vous pouvez consulter le site du
département au www.cegedim.fr
[Musique]